JUDICIARY TODAY'S THURSDAY
AUGUST TWENTY THIRD.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM TO HEAR IT IS A
CONCURRENCE ITEM AND THIS IS AB
[inaudible]
SIX SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING GUM AS
MISS PIGGY PUT OFF SOMETIMES
SAYS POOR MORE.
JUST THREE I THINK THIS IS SO
YOU'RE ONLYYOU'RE ONLY GOOD
MATTER OUT AT THIS IS SET AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN WHICH WOULD
PERMIT INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE.
A PREVIOUSLY I AM --
A TYPICALLY IN THE TRIAL COURT
BEEN GRANTED ACCESS BY THE
JUVENILE COURT TO INSPECT AND
RECEIVE COPY THE CASE FILES FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THEN
PARTICIPATING IN AN APPEAL.
UP BY ELIMINATING THE NECESSITY
FOR SPECIAL PROCEEDINGS TO
AUTHORIZE THE INDIVIDUAL'S
ACCESS TO THESE RECORDS.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD INCREASE
EFFICIENCY AND ACCESS TO JUSTICE
WELL THE SAME TIME REDUCING
COSTS AND DELAYS FOR THE PARTIES
AND THE COURTS [inaudible]
AT THE DOUBLE BENEFIT SO PRUE
COULD ARGUE WITH THAT IN FACT
NOBODY HAS SAYS NO OPPOSITION.
OF THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
THE PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
APPEAL THE CASE HAVE THE RIGHT
INFORMATION HELP THEIR APPEAL.
THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND I'M PLEASED
TO HAVE WITH ME AND THE
LIEBERMAN BOMB TO TEST MY
FURTHER.
ON THE ON THE BILL.
I WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM IT
SEEMS WE DO WE WILL.
WE DO LET'S ESTABLISH COURT
FIRST STONE HERE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU.
CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REST.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO I'LL TAKE
THAT MOTION.
RIGHT IT'S BEEN MOVED TO CONCUR
THE MOTION IS THAT WE CAN CAR
AND THE BUILDING GOES TO THE
FLOOR.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE I AM VIEW
EVEN VON JUDICIAL COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ALSO TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM.
HE SAID IT VERY SUCCINCTLY AND
ALSO IN THE ANALYSIS WERE
TALKING ABOUT A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY HAVE HAD ACCESS TO
FILES SO WE WANT TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS FOR APPEALS AND
RITZ.
I IN THE OFF CHANCE THAT THAT
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THE CHILD
WELFARE CASES SO WITH THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WOULD
ANYONE.
ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NOT AS THEIR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SING NOT.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
AS A SAID THAT MOTION IS THAT WE
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS AND
SEND THE BILL TO THE FLOOR.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
OF I DON'T REGULARLY AFTER AYE
VOTE THANK.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KELLY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
SO THAT BEEN LIST OUT AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN AND MEMBERS
IT LOOKS LIKE WE MAY HAVE.
AN ITEM OR TWO THAT WE WILL
PROBABLY HERE NEXT WEEK SO STAY
TUNED WILL PROBABLY END UP DOING
THAT OTHER HEARING OFF THE
FLOOR.
I THINK IT WAS FOR THEM.
SO ALL THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW
MINUTES IF THE ABSENT MEMBERS
COULD -- AND
WE COULD.
AND THEN WE CAN ADJOURN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
WHAT?
UP WITH THAT BOTH OF THEM SO
WE'RE GOING TO THAT THE ROLE IS
STILL OPEN CALL THE UPS MEMBERS
PLEASE CUNNINGHAM AYE AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE REYES.
AYE REYES AYE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE ARE.
WE ARE ADJOURNED